[Music]
I have a lot of skills, so I am
very attracted to the fact that there are no limits. I
am happy. During baking, I
can show what I have been practicing. Thank you
[Music]
My name is Im Gun
Yoo.  I'm
using a nickname
early now, I'm specializing in mold king,
so I'm working outside, yes, now, through performances
Because it uses a kick with a sense of purpose,
yes
Sponge Do is the best form
of Korean traditional booze for a long time
I think it
contains Korean lunches and keys
I
just fell in love with taekwondo without realizing it, so
why did I start? I
was still doing
taekwondo. Is there anything more flashy in
the middle
?  However, my hair removal was 140 degrees
and I started
kicking kicks like this in my second year of middle school.
As I started that kick, I
also started Yonsei, and
it’s not as difficult as I thought.
[Music]
People who exercise in Korea make a
living with it.  I see
a lot of people looking at
me with this kind of
gaze.  ]